so the thing is that the mental model
hacks so I'll give you an example of
like one of the mental model hacks right
so
Buffett says that if you hang out with
people better than you
you will get better
if you hang out with people worse than
you you will get worse so they're the
gravitational pull either way now it
should be apparent that we should hang
out with people better than us
but then the question is how do we know
someone is better than us
and
one of the hacks that Charlie uses
is that sometimes you're going to meet
some people
and it's going to be obvious that these
are amazing great people high quality
people gonna be very obvious
bring them into the Inner Circle I asked
Warren at the lunch I told I told Warren
how come you are such a great judge of
humans
he said monish you are mistaken I am not
a great judge of humans he said if you
put me in a cocktail party with a
hundred people
and I met all hundred of them for let's
say two minutes right he said I could
probably tell you
that three or four people were amazing
great people
I could probably also tell you that
three or four people are people I want
to have nothing to do with
right and the other 92 I would not have
any interest in I I would not know how
to rank them or rate them
so the Hack That Buffett uses and Monger
uses
they will not try to figure out the 92.
that's too much work
they will just bring in the top three
four percent into their Circle
and they will treat the bad people and
the Unknown People the same
which is take so basically now this is
unfair
someone could be really good and now
you've excluded them but the thing is
because there are infinite number of
humans on Earth
and therefore mathematically there are
infinite number of great people on Earth
because three percent of infinity is
still Infinity the fact that you exclude
a lot of great people there's no penalty
to be paid just like if we
buy a great company and exclude a great
company we don't pay a penalty but if
you include a bad company we pay a
penalty so the hack is that you don't
try to figure it out
you just go with the no-brainers and so
now that becomes really fast right in
terms of sifting through humans and all
that so even when they're looking at
companies and businesses and Business
Leaders and all that they just look for
are they in the three four percent I
obviously know are great and so just
this particular hack would give you a
huge leg up because most humans will you
know first of all they won't even have
this model of you know not interacting
with people not so good I mean that's
the first hack you use is you're gonna
only deal with great people
for example when I started playing
bridge with Charlie
I met his friends
okay
every time I made met a friend friend of
his I said wow
this guy is really amazing what what an
extremely high quality human being so I
did a hack I said every friend of
Charlie is a friend of mine okay I don't
need to figure it out he's already
figured it out and so I built
relationships with all these friends of
Charlie and they are I just look at them
and every time I think about the way
they are and we are talking and such the
quality level is so high and then you
know when you just spend your time with
these types of people all the time
life life becomes so amazing
so that book
this particular Nuance is just one
little piece there's a lot of other
pieces in there that's amazing I guess
you are a no-brainer for Charlie Monger
monish so you should feel very proud
I feel that one day both these guys are
gonna figure out that I'm a fraud I'm
gonna figure out
I always think you know I'm just I'm
just a kid from the suburbs of Mumbai
okay I said one day they're gonna figure
out that once in a while they make an
errand judgment they made an errand
judgment with me and then that's going
to be the end of the lunches and the
bridge games okay now hasn't happened so
far we're still in the game hopefully it
continues but I know one day they're
gonna figure it out
yeah someone asked a question about
decision making so I put up a tweet
recently that said if you can't decide
the answer is no
and uh I think that's a the reason I I
have decision making heuristics that I
use uh and actually there are three
decision making heuristics that I use
and it's very hard to come up with a
decision-making heuristic because
there's infinite choices we're making
all day long and uh trying to figure out
like some rule that applied to all the
choices is really difficult so obviously
these rules are not going to apply to
everything you have to be intelligent
about when to use them and when not to
make it when not to use them first is if
I'm faced with a difficult Choice such
as should I marry this person
should I take this job should I buy this
house should I move the city should I go
in business with this person
if you cannot decide the answer is no
and the reason is because modern society
is full of options there are tons and
tons of options we live in a planet of
seven billion people we are connected to
everybody on the internet there's
hundreds of thousands of careers
available to you there are so many
choices you're biologically not built to
realize how many choices there are
because we evolved in tribes or tribes
of 150 people where if you pass up one
choice the second thing never comes
along also when you
something it takes you get locked in for
a long time if you start a business
that's 10 years you get into a
relationship that's five years maybe
more you move to a city that's 10 20
years so these are very very long lived
decisions so it's very very important
that you only say yes when you are
pretty certain you're never going to be
absolutely certain but you're going to
be very positive if you find yourself
creating a spreadsheet for a decision
with a list of yeses and no's and pros
and cons and checks and balances and why
you know why is this is good or why
that's bad forget it yeah you have to
internalize it in your gut and in your
heart and you have to really want
something before you go for it so my
first decision making heuristic is if
you cannot decide the answer is no if I
would recommend one book I would say it
would be poor Charlie's Almanac I would
say that I try to reread that book every
year and every year I read stuff that I
can swear I never read before you know
so it's like it's the gift that keeps on
giving and the book is in two parts you
know the second part of the book is more
interesting which has all the different
great talks that Charlie gave
and one particular talk he gave at
Harvard many years ago she updated for
the book the psychology of human
misjudgment I think that is just
incredible it's about 50 pages in the
book and
if you mastered Incorporated the lessons
of that essay it would give you a huge
advantage in life you know one one thing
I realized with all the time I spent
with Charlie
is I realized that okay he's got
incredible horsepower
you know horsepower Beyond anyone I've
met
but it's not just the horsepower he is
pounding into his brain
close to four or five hundred books a
year
I mean the prolific rate that he's
reading is very high it's more than a
book a day so he's pounding in four or
five hundred books a year
probably for the last
seven or eight decades that he's been
pounding so you know if you take like
you know 80 years you know that's like
40 000 books it's a lot of books and
then plus there's annual reports and
newspapers and magazines and all of that
but that's not even it the thing what
what Charlie has done and that's why
that essay is so important
so he has the amazing brain and he's
populated that brain with a lot of data
which is important data but the third
hack that he has
is the hack of mental models
so what he's done with all that 40 000
books of whatever he's read and all the
life experience he's had is he's figured
out certain
hacks about the way humans are
and if you figure out those hacks which
is what he mentions in that essay
because that that essay basically in
effect took him 50 years to get the
wisdom to write that essay that gives
you just a huge Head Start
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you